est-ce que tu sais qu'il s'ouvre lui
c'est déjà sa troisième rentrée scolaire
dès le début on sait à peu près à quoi
notre année va ressembler Audrey de veau
fait partie de la première cote d'un
programme unique au Québec elle suit ses
cours en enseignement prise scolaire et
primaire deux jours par semaine à Sétif
les mardis mercredis sont réservés à
l'université le reste de la semaine
on est disponible
puis ça jusqu'en juin parce qu'on a une
session d'été aussi qui commence en
avril donc notre horaire est assez
stable toute l'année là pendant son bac
elle peut recevoir jusqu'à 70% du
salaire complet d'une enseignante moi je
trouve ça super bien parce que ce qu'on
apprend à l'école on peut rapidement le
mettre en pratique donc ce que les
enseignants nous enseignent c'est plus
concret c'est plus significatif
ils sont une vingtaine d'étudiants comme
Audrey a enseigné sur la côte nord en
cette rentrée scolaire parfois titulaire
mais plus souvent
à un autre enseignant si on n'avait pas
ce programme là localement je vous dirai
on aurait énormément discuté à souris
l'enseignement Richard Poirier dirige le
Centre de Services scolaire du fer ou
cet automne chaque classe a son
enseignant parmi les 23 qui ne sont pas
encore diplômés la majorité sont déjà
inscrits au programme on desserre aussi
des élèves qui sont à Saint-Pierre qui
sont à faire monter donc là on a la
chance d'avoir des gens qui se font qui
sont chez nous qui en plus prennent
d'expérience
en stage dans la même école Tanya suit
la même formation Audrey et ta maman de
deux enfants quitter la région pour moi
c'est difficile donc j'ai sauté sur
l'occasion c'est parfait pour moi le
conciliation travail famille
Clémentine c'est très exigeant c'est
c'est trois cours par session plus notre
travail plus la la vie qui continue à
être à côté de ça donc oui il faut être
prêt à donner du temps
ces étudiants viennent de commencer le
même programme en cette rentrée 2022
aura donc dû attendre trois ans pour
avoir les inscriptions suffisantes afin
de former une deuxième courte la covid
n'aidant pas c'est pour ça aussi que
l'université existe là c'est pour
répondre aux besoins sociétaux on voit
que c'est un bon arrimage entre le
travail et les études je pense que les
étudiants se ressentent aussi le fait
que la formation est adaptée à leurs
besoins ce programme est-il une solution
à la pénurie d'enseignants de passage
sur la côte nord la présidente de la
Fédération des syndicats d'enseignement
à aimer ces conditions il faut que ces
gens-là soient accompagnés ne soient pas
laissés à eux seuls mais l'initiative
ajoute-t-elle et très bonne on est
capable de trouver des solutions locales
qui viennent aider à une pénurie locale
on peut pas se permettre de mettre ça de
côté est-ce que c'est le besoin partout
au Québec je sais pas faudra mieux le
faire connaître faudra le regarder ça
t'intéresse pas Tania et Audrey
obtiendront leur diplôme en 2024
déterminer à faire leur carrière chez
elle acide
vraiment parfait pour moi l'Université
du Québec à Chicoutimi en collaboration
avec l'Université du Québec à Rimouski
envisage maintenant détendre ce
programme dans toute la côte nord mais
aussi dans le bassin Laurent en Gaspésie
et aux Îles de la Madeleine ils espèrent
pouvoir former une nouvelle cohort
d'étudiants enseignants chaque année à
partir de l'an prochain ici
jean-Sébastien Cloutier Radio-Canada
s'est-il